no
[Música]
con nuestro segundo enfoque de nuestro
tema del día que sobre la polémica
desatada tras las declaraciones en el
senado estadounidense de la ex empleada
de facebook france house es quien
aseguró que la compañía presionaba por
mayores ganancias sin importar los
usuarios con énfasis en especial en
atraer a los niños ante esto mark
zuckerberg negó que las cosas en la
empresa ocurran de esa forma como ella
lo describió y que sólo trabajó con
ellos durante dos años joven previamente
filtró documentos internos de la
compañía al diario wall street journal
donde asegura que la gigante de las
redes sociales antepone sus beneficios a
la seguridad de los usuarios también
oculta que sus plataformas son nocivas
para los menores y fomentan la división
social y debilitan la democracia eso
dice allí también los documentos que
filtró para ello quiero saludar en
nuestro segundo invitado del día ls
luisen noguerol experto en
ciberseguridad y también
telecomunicaciones trabaja para el
departamento del comercio de eeuu y
manejó la operación de toda la costa
este del país gracias por estar con
nosotros son muy buen día luis por estar
aquí
américa cuál es la ética de estas
compañías cuál debe ser lo que deberían
hacer para cuidarlos a nosotros como
usuarios
claro urbanos de viajes muchas gracias
por la invitación
bueno en términos de eficaz
desafortunadamente yo creo que estamos
ante una crisis
en términos de esto específicamente en
el caso de facebook definitivamente no
está sigue todas las reglas para eso no
necesitamos
digamos analizar muchas cosas desde el
año 93
eeuu secundan en federal para la
protección de la seguridad de los
menores online específicamente también
se conoce como copa s pp-a no y la ley
dice que es una ley federal es el mismo
bajo la administración del ex presidente
clinton y se puso en práctica en el año
2002 del puente la ley claramente
formula las precauciones que empresas
como facebook
necesitan tener en cuenta para la
protección de los menores eso
definitivamente no está ocurriendo
bajen cooper justos más significativos
de la ley para darse cuenta que en
facebook en este caso y muchas otras
compañías pues no están observando al
contenido de la ley no
es por supuesto de esperar la reacción
del mark zuckerberg el presidente de
facebook hasta después de la
presentación de francés en el congreso
en la audiencia del día
es
incluso doloroso pensar que empresas de
este calibre que por supuesto manera una
cantidad de dinero superficial
porque estas empresas no respetan la ley
louis
bueno imagino yo diría que poner la
gente
de ambición personal yo cuando estaba en
la seguridad de los niños de las
personas mayores que son los sectores
más vulnerables de cualquier sociedad
están en riesgo yo dejo de entender que
la empresa es por supuesto la empresa
número uno ante el planeta tierra maneja
más de 3 mil 500 millones de conexiones
al día estamos hablando de una empresa
que por supuesto no tiene nada que ver
con una empresa común con típica esto es
definitivamente una empresa artística en
el sentido de la operación que manera la
pregunta a hacerse acá es si alguien
puede tener sin la ley no puede detener
el llamar shock en vélez en el año 2011
había estado
claramente en contra de la ley en
nuestra audiencia en el senado de los
eeuu sin que éste fue la primera vez
hace diez años que él estuvo totalmente
en desacuerdo con la ley como se propone
con se aprobó ahora si el problema
digamos en este caso está más que todo
enfocado en los menores de edad que
entran a estas redes sociales en
propiedad de facebook porque no se hace
una ley o porque no se regula que las
personas que puedan usar estas redes
sociales pues tengan que ser mayores de
edad para poder disfrutar desde después
la red como tal
bueno es precisamente eso es parte de la
ley la ley dice que los menores de 13
años no pueden usarla no pueden crear
una cuenta en una red social a no ser
que tengan el consentimiento de los
padres e incluso se maneja en algún
momento por parte de facebook
la colección de datos biométricos para
poder verificar lea hoy no existe el
tema de verificación de la en ninguna
red social
especialmente en facebook o sea lo que
ella lo que francés explicó ayer ingresó
que en facebook vídeo audio no tiene el
músculo tecnológico es necesario para
verificar la edad es donde comienza el
problema pues no lo hace así que eso es
parte juntamente de la ley la ley desde
el año o sea se creó en el año 98
y luego se verificó se revisó la ley en
el año 2013 y informe a compañías con
facebook a verificar la edad de los
veedores no ocurre no lo hace que tiene
que ser a su parecer mañana digamos
facebook para poder frenar esto además
con esta acusación de que la red social
aumenta el odio la división realmente la
empresa puede controlar su contenido en
la red social
a ver controlar el contenido una red
social es difícil no importa cuántos
algoritmos se pongan en el mundo no
importa en la forma en la que se diseña
el alboroto necesitamos entender como
usuarios que
primero hay un concepto que el concepto
de libertad de expresión significa la
libertad de expresión en facebook o en
cualquier otro lugar todo un poco que
deja de sonar
apropiado porque imágenes entonces ya
nos están cuestionando que por qué no la
respuesta a su pregunta es se puede en
facebook verificar todo el contenido
teóricamente sí en la práctica no ocurre
ahora que puede ser facebook
definitivamente en cortar algoritmos
desarrollo e incluso facebook usa una
combinación de herramientas
tradicionales y en
las herramientas de inteligencia
artificial y también de inteligencia de
negocios
de las personas
es cien por ciento así desde el punto de
vista tecnológico se metió un tema
espinoso que pues ya que le tocó también
se le quería preguntar dónde queda
entonces la libertad
de un lado totalmente a los otros está
controlado por la empresa como facebook
necesita encontrar un punto de balance a
mí no me parece apropiado el límite que
puedes comer sino entonces nos estamos
convirtiendo digamos en
somos parte de una acción que tiene
mucho que ver con dictadores y este tipo
de cosas alimentarnos que puede producir
desde de seguir adelante pero si hay
cosas que se deben verificar
el número uno y debería hacerlo no sólo
para facebook sino para todo el mundo
para autores activos los menores y las
personas de la tercera edad son los
sectores más vulnerables de la sociedad
si los que pueden hacer algo como
facebook no lo hacen entonces es
extremadamente doloroso pero estamos
después
pues gracias por su tiempo por conversar
con nosotros este tema tan polémico y
tan difícil como ya también lo dijo
sobre las libertades sobre facebook y
sobre las redes sociales gracias y feliz
día
muchas de base usted es siempre uno